هو اضخم اضراب في بريطانيا منذ عشر سنوات
الاف العمال بينهم موظف الخدمه المدنيه
والمحاضرون الجامعيون والمدرسون و سائق
قطارات وداعمهم في مسيره احتجاج شقت
طريقها من وسط لندن باتجاه مقر رئاسه
الحكومه للمطالبه بتحسين الاجور وظروف
العمل من
اجورنا فعليا
وحتى مع زياده المطروحه فان تضخم خفض
رواتبنا
الكلمه
منذ فتره الوباء وعدم تقديم زياده في
الاجور ولا زياده لدعم التلاميذ الضعفاء
الذين تاثروا بالوباء
الاف ونقاط الاعتصام شكلها المضربون عن
العمل في مختلف القطاعات للضغط على
الحكومه التي طرحت رفع الاجور بنسبه 5%
وهو ما ترفضه النقابات في ظل نسبه التضخم
تجاوزت 10 في المئه وغلاء معيشه غير مسبوق
ريش هناك اذان الاضرابات التي اجبرت
ملايين التلاميذ على التغيب عن المدارس
وانتقد السياسه رئيس حزب العمال المنحزه
للنقابات
لمعارضه مشروع قانون يؤمن الحد الادنى من
السلامه كما سوت مع مجموعه اوقف استخداما
النفط لتخفيف من قانون النظام العامه
المشترك بين النقابات ومجموعه اوقف النفط
زعيم المعارضه كير ستار مار من جهته لام
حزب المحافظين الحاكمه لفشله في التعاطي
مع الاضرابات
بعد ثلاثه عشر عاما في السلطه يريد لون
حزب العمال على فشله في ايجاد حل
للاضرابات انه امر مثير للشفقه حزب
المحافظين صار مدمنا على الفساد والفضائح
اضرابات مجدوله في عدد من القطاعات هذا
الاسبوع والاسبوع المقبل ولا مؤشره على
الغائها ما التعثر المفاوضات بين الحكومه
والنقابات
في ما تتمسك الحكومه بزياده رواتب معقوله
تقول نقابه العمال ان الاضرابه مؤشر على
غضب اعضائها وتحذر من المزيد منها ما لم
تطرح الحكومه مقترحات ملموسه وذات مغزى
بشان رفع الاجور مصطفى زارو العربيه لندن